bonjour à tous bienvenue sur les chaînes
parlementaires seller de parlement hebdo
rendez vous que vous pouvez retrouver
pendant 45 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire à
mes côtés aujourd'hui géré landrieu
bonjour mon nom et dans les titres la
révision constitutionnelle adoptée à
l'assemblée nationale elle inscrit la
déchéance de nationalité et l'état
d'urgence dans la loi satisfaction
manuel valls qui se dit convaincu
qu'elle sera adoptée par une majorité au
congrès maintenant la balle est dans le
camp des sénateurs une semaine également
le nouveau gouvernement valls 3 un
remaniement marqué par plusieurs retours
celui de jean marc ayrault aux affaires
étrangères et le retour des verts avec
notamment la patronne emmanuelle cosse
par été respectée 19 hommes et dix neuf
femmes dont semblait que la
présidentielle est bien là proche une
proposition de loi déjà adopté par
l'assemblée de modifier les règles en
matière de parrainage financement de
campagne mais aussi temps de parole dans
les médias au détriment des petits
candidats qui se disent inquiets et pour
commenter avec nous cette semaine
politique notre invité c'est christophe
béchu bonjour sénateur du maine et loire
maire d'angers vous allez commenter
jour après jour cette semaine politique
on va commencer à l'assemblée nationale
lundi l'assemblée a voté l'article 1 de
la révision constitutionnelle sur l'état
d'urgence
eq 103 voix pour et 26 contre
l'assemblée a adopté lundi soir un
article 1 qui vise l'inscription dans la
constitution de l'état d'urgence le
texte initial a été peu modifié à
retenir le contrôle parlementaire de
l'état d'urgence et une durée maximale
de prorogation de quatre mois on regarde
le sujet de rim benameur l'état
d'urgence désormais inscrit dans la
constitution l'article 2 1 a été adopté
l'état d'urgence sera décrétée en
conseil des ministres et seul le
parlement pourra prolonger sa durée au
delà de douze jours les débats se sont
cristallisées sur la durée maximale un
amendement udi a été adopté pour le
limiter à quatre mois renouvelable
il nous paraît très regrettable qu'on
installe ou qu'on laisse la possibilité
d'installer un état d'urgence quasi
permanent qui serait par exemple d'une
durée initiale que sais-je de lits mois
dix mois 12 mois alors qu évidemment
personne n'est capable en période de
crise d'imaginer ou d'évaluer ce que
sera la menace at-elle échéance les
députés ont aussi ajouté le principe
d'un contrôle parlementaire sur
l'organisation de l'état d'urgence
voulue par plusieurs groupes
le gouvernement y était favorable tout
en émettant quelques réserves
si le parlement dans sa sagesse décide
d'élever des éléments au rang
constitutionnel le peu le gouvernement
respecte la volonté du parlement mais
stricto sensu
nous avons pu construire un contrôle
parlementaire sans que sa figure dans la
constitution
en revanche c'est contre l'avis du
gouvernement qu'un autre amendement a
été adopté selon cet amendement
l'assemblée se réunit de plein droit et
ne peut être dissoute pendant l'état
d'urgence une disposition trop éloignées
des objectifs du texte selon manuel
valls le gouvernement ne souhaite pas
aller sur d'autres sujets et notamment
sur la question de la dissolution
parce qu'on voit bien qu'on touche tout
de suite à d'autres éléments il faudra
sans doute revenir sur l'amendement qui
a été adopté tout à l'heure quand j
revenir c'est sur le fond du débat
l'article à adopter les députés se sont
lancés dans l'examen de l'article le
plus critique est celui sur la déchéance
de nationalité
le vote sur l'ensemble du texte aura
lieu le 10
riez alors qu'elles savent béchu le
contrôle parlementaire de cet état
d'urgence
il reste à définir par les deux
assemblées mais c'est une bonne chose
que vous preniez en main une façon assez
large se contrôle parlementaire de
l'état d'urgence oui c'est une bonne
chose
on va évidemment attendre les débats qui
vont avoir lieu ici au sénat autour de
cette révision constitutionnelle
l'inscription dans la constitution de
l'état d'urgence ça permettra de le
bordé de dire ce qu'il ya dedans où ça
commence
et comment ça s'arrête mais le fait que
évidemment on bascule pas dans un
système où les pleins pouvoirs serait
donné à l'exécutif c'est une nécessité
absolue
quand vous voyez les images dans
l'hémicycle l'année musicale n'était pas
très très nombreux quand même ça vous a
choqué ou une certaine polémique en
début de semaine oui il ya une polémique
été chassé par d'autres polémiques on
est on est déjà là bravo da semaine bon
moi je pense honnêtement aussi que le
gouvernement une responsabilité
pourquoi parce qu'en faisant commencer
un débat un vendredi sur un sujet soit
disant centrale est cruciale ils
savaient très bien que compte tenu de ce
que sont les habitudes de travail des
saints et des autres ça n'aboutirait pas
à une présence forte et une présence
massive et je pense d'ailleurs pour
partie qui n'est pas mécontent qui ait
eu un débat où une polémique sur la
présence des députés plutôt que sur le
fond du texte et sur les divisions que
ça suscite à l'intérieur de la majorité
est pour l'article de l'hémicycle était
bien remplie le lendemain on a bien vu
mais tout de même on est revenu sur
cette dissolution c'est possible
dissolution de l'assemblée pendant
l'état d'urgence s'était il ne fallait
pas confondre les objectifs de cette
révision constitutionnelle dire on peut
pas dissoudre
quand il ya un état d'urgence ckoi
l'étape d'après on n'organise plus
d'élections qu'anti un état d'urgence
là-haut change de régime on modifie
l'équilibré pouvoir vous savez plus
largement sur la constitution on a fait
une révision mineure soit disant
mineures passé le mandat présidentiel de
sept ans à 5 ans les conséquences on n'a
toujours pas fini de les mesurer
aujourd'hui sur l' équilibre des
institutions et sur la manière dont ça
change les choses dire demain on se
contente de constitutionnaliser l'état
d'urgence il commençait à ajouter
l'interdiction dissolution la
modification des équilibres des pouvoirs
entre parlement et exécutif
c'est jouer avec le feu et dans des
conditions où la sérénité et le temps
pour regarder les choses n'existe par le
quai attention à toute modification à
leur répercussion toujours lundi après
le vote de cet article 1 les débats sur
l'article 2 était bien sûr très attendu
c'est l'article qui concernait la
déchéance de nationalité
certains députés étaient à vif ils ont
expliqué leur choix avec émotion c'est
le cas du centriste charles de courson
le député est divisible mans ému a
expliqué pourquoi ils allaient voter en
faveur de cet article deux en écoute la
déchéance de nationalité limitée aux
seuls binationaux soit 5 % de nos
concitoyens telle qu'elle était prévue
dans le projet initial du gouvernement
et qui traduisait ce choix exposé à
versailles par le président de la
république était inacceptable parce
qu'elle était contraire à l'unité de
notre nation voté pour ce texte c'était
trahir la mémoire de mon grand-père
député de la nation mort à neuengamme et
qui avaient voté contre les pleins
pouvoirs au maréchal pétain
parce que il était contre le sabordage
de la république
par contre le vôtre est la nouvelle
rédaction de l'article 2 parce qu'elle
permet d'appliquer la déchéance de
nationalité à tous les français
condamnés pour des crimes et des délits
graves en lien avec le terrorisme
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale mon
père était résistant à des qualités de
terroristes par l'occupant nazi parce
qu'il avait pris des armes et ils
avaient été qualifiées de terroristes
non pas par des juridictions
indépendante mais par l'occupant et donc
voter pour cet article 2 dans sa
nouvelle rédaction ne trahira pas la
mémoire de mon père néanmoins
l'indignité nationale eut été une
meilleure solution et aurait évité la
désunion nationale
alors voilà vous l'avez vu c'était une
séquence athénée assez inédite
bien sûr de chaque dans chaque camp
politique il y à il ya des calculs
politiques mais on peut pas exclure que
c'est aussi un choix très intime pour
chaque parlementaire avec des histoires
personnelles
oui je pense que c'est on l'ad'ailleurs
bien vu
à l'arrivée avec les votes il n'y a pas
deux parties dans lesquelles les vote a
été unanime dans un sens ou dans un
autre
4 restons un peu sur l'émotion de
charles de courson c'est rare cette
image quand même dans un hémicycle
céréales et transparaître cette émotion
pour un homme politique c'est rare mais
dans beaucoup de cas les textes sur
lesquels nous votons ne se prête pas à
une forme d'émotion beaucoup de textes
non pas la dimension la porter la
puissance d'asie mais là évidemment
encore une fois on touche à la
constitution les attentats du 13
novembre nous ont fait basculer dans
quelque chose où la force des débats des
symboles le poids de la révision que
nous demande le président de la
république sont presque sans précédent
donc vous êtes quelques pas beaucoup
d'entre nous dire que plus rien ne sera
comme avant on peut plus faire de la
politique comme on la faisait avant et
pourtant si on vous regarde bien le jeu
politique actuellement il n'y a pas eu
de changement non je dis juste que avec
les chaînes d'info en continu avec les
flux d'informations auxquelles on est
soumis
on pourrait croire que ce qui s'est
passé le 13 novembre c'était il ya très
longtemps
la vérité c'est c'était un petit peu
plus de trois mois mais que dans le même
temps dans ce laps de temps si court
nous sommes invités à nous prononcer sur
des points de révision constitutionnelle
qui évidemment n'ont pas fait l'objet
d'une réflexion ou d'une maturation
comme d'autres sujets qui peuvent
exister dans la vie politique depuis
longtemps le poids de la fiscalité le
niveau des charges sociales le fait de
savoir quel est le bon équilibre entre
sécurité justice la question de la
déchéance de la nationalité elle a fait
un petit tour en termes d'apparitions
sous le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
avec un discours et le rugby est là elle
revient mais elle revient avec une
configuration politique qui n'a plus
rien à voir dans un contexte qui n'a
plus rien à voir sans aucun consensus
n'est 100 m sont déjà tellement de
version depuis le 13 novembre va parler
un petit peu de ce qui arrive au sénat
c'était mardi on a voté l'état d'urgence
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence
c'est le ministre de l'intérieur qui est
venu au sénat pour annoncer la
prolongation de cet état d'urgence trois
mois et coûté manakana l'exception au
droit commun fait partie intégrante de
l'histoire républicaine française tout
état démocratique
en effet le devoir de prévoir un
dispositif d'exception susceptible de
lui donner les moyens de droit pour
faire face à une situation d'une extrême
gravité
mais il doit bien évidemment le faire
dans le respect scrupuleux des principes
démocratiques et en prévoyant les
garanties permettant de s'assurer qu'il
en sera fait un usage strictement
nécessaire la loi du 3 avril 1955
relatives à l'état d'urgence visent à
sienne nous permettent de lutter contre
tout péril imminent résultant d'atteinte
grave à l'ordre public ou contre des
événements je cite présentant par leur
nature et leur gravité
le caractère de calamité publique nul ne
conteste ici j'en suis convaincu que les
attentats du 13 novembre s'inscrivait
dans ce cadre mais si nous devons faire
preuve de fermeté et de détermination
nous devons également agir dans la
pleine conscience de la responsabilité
qui est la nôtre l'état d'urgence n'est
pas le contraire de l'état de droit
il en est au contraire dès lors que la
situation l'exigent le bouclier
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu lire ici
ou là parfois dans la presse
l'état d'urgence est donc pas synonyme
d'arbitraire les raisons justifiant d'y
avoir recours
sa déclaration comme sa prorogation
ainsi que les actes et des décisions
prises sur son fondement sont tous
prévus est strictement encadrée par la
loi
christophe béchu jacques toubon qui est
le défenseur des droits d il ya très peu
tôt nous étions rentrés dans l'ère des
suspects ont prolongé l'état d'urgence
tout le monde dit que c'est plutôt
raisonnable de le faire
vous estimez vous qu'il peut y avoir des
dérives hollande a view from a connu et
bien à 15,9 en a parlé également encore
une fois pourquoi on est dans cette
situation
les attentats à cause des attentats
est-ce qu'il était souhaitable après les
attentats de ne rien faire
bien sûr que non est-ce qu'il était
souhaitable de prendre des mesures en
faire ça c'est un autre sujet moi je
trouve qu'on n'a pas suffisamment fait
après charlie j'aurais mauvaise grâce
aujourd'hui à considérer qu'on a trop
fait après des résultats du bataclan et
je préfère la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence avec un retour régulier devant
le parlement pour échanger sur un
certain nombre de sujets plutôt que la
précipitation de la révision
constitutionnelle pour être clair parce
que on fixe la des règles pour
maintenant dans le cas de la révision
constitutionnelle
on les modifier pour toujours c'est un
consensus politique sur ce point puisque
effectivement c'est une attente des
français aujourd'hui il fallait
prolonger cet état d'urgence et en même
temps il ya aussi une urgence à faire à
l'inscrire dans la constitution pourquoi
pour fixer un cadre les règles du jeu
oui moi je crois deux choses d'abord
indépendamment de la tente des français
parce que c'est pas une bonne manière de
légiférer que de faire un sondage pour
ensuite savoir ce qu'il faut faire mais
très simplement aujourd'hui quand on
voit la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes
est ce que l'état d'urgence a permis en
terme de perquisition en termes
d'assignation il est raisonnable est
souhaitable de maintenir ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas avoir conscience
qu'il ya un certain nombre d'excès ou
d'abus
c'est aussi pour ça que les tribunaux
sont là mais globalement les avantages
l'emportent très largement sur les
inconvénients compte tenu de la
situation et du péril dans lequel nous
sommes une question très courte ça va
s'arrêter avant l'euro de foot qui va
être organisé en france est raisonnable
de l'arrêter avant je ne comprends pas
cette manière de de présenter les choses
l'état d'urgence il doit être dictée par
les circonstances
pas par la date des événements donc vous
l'arrêté quand vous considérez qu'il ya
plus lieu de maintenir dire par avance
on l'arrêtera parce qu'ensuite il va y
avoir des matches de foot en france pour
le coup c'est à mon sens ou peut-être
les éléments dans un environnement
international tous ceux qui vont venir
en france
mais à ce moment là encore une fois il
faut de la cohérence
et globalement c'est qu'un estimant que
le plus à ce gouvernement depuis le
début du quinquennat
on a une situation s'il ya un danger on
maintient d'état d'urgence parce qu'on
considère qu'on a des raisons de le
faire
s'il n'y a pas de danger on le lev est
ce que l'euro va faire diminuer le
danger ou est ce qu'au contraire la
multiplication de rencontres de dizaines
de milliers de personnes se rendant dans
des stades de visiteurs venant étrangers
augmente le risque en tout cas niveau
c'est que tu es sera une priorité
puisque ça a été rappelé pour cet
événement on va on va continuer le cimp
et y laisse abéché retour dans
l'hémicycle avec le vote de l'article 2
c'était l'article le plus attendu sur la
déchéance de nationalité
les débats étaient très vif il n'y a
aucun consensus du côté de la majorité
ni l'opposition
retour sur un vote très politique avec
ce sujet le céline martèle le scrutin
est ouvert
tout s'est joué à seulement quatorze
voix d'écart la déchéance de nationalité
est adoptée de justesse
l'article le plus controversé du projet
de loi a divisé l'hémicycle surtout
parmi les socialistes
là où nous avons besoin de concorde
démocratique là où les français se sont
spontanément rassemblés après les
attentats
ce débat sur la déchéance de nationalité
créer de la discorde sur les 148 vote
contre 81,12 yens d'élus du ps pour
défendre son texte jean jacques urvoas
invoque le principe d'égalité entre les
citoyens
la déchéance de nationalité ne vis plus
explicitement les binationaux né
français
toute personne condamnée pour terrorisme
doit pouvoir être déchu de la
nationalité quel que soit le mode
d'acquisition de cette nationalité
à droite les républicains se sont eux
aussi divisés 32 votes pour suivant les
consignes du chef du parti nicolas
sarkozy 30 votes contre inscrire dans la
constitution ce que vous nous proposez
est il utile de ces dangereux
3 c'est mal placé à mesure que s'empare
de l'hémicycle une certaine confusion
je voudrais pour ma part très
directement réaffirmer une conviction
que oui il faut inscrire dans le texte
constitutionnel dans la loi fondamentale
de la république
ce principe de la déchéance de
nationalité
chez les écologistes seul françois de
rugy a voté en faveur de la déchéance de
nationalité le chemin de la révision
constitutionnelle est encore long le
texte passera au sénat le mois prochain
les sénateurs de droite en majorité dans
la haute chambre ont déjà annoncé leur
intention de réécrire le texte
alors on va se concentrer sur le vote
des républicains qui sauvent béchu où la
vue c'est 50 50 c'est très difficile de
trouver une politique pourtant nicolas
sarkozy était venu le matin même à
l'assemblée pour essayer de convaincre
une dernière fois les députés de voter
en faveur notamment de cet article 2
quel est aujourd'hui votre point de vue
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
trouver un consensus au sein des
républicains sur ce sujet honnêtement
c'est pas mon sujet le sujet c'est le
texte qui va être votée c'est pas de
savoir ce qui va se passer à l'intérieur
du groupe politique des républicains à
l'assemblée ou au sénat
c'est quel texte la représentation
nationale adopte à l'arrivée les
bisbilles internes au ps entre les
frondeurs et les autres les propos
virulents de fonds au sein des veines
mêmes répliques d'un film de bien faire
être l'air autres certains sénateurs ont
certains députés moi ce que je constate
ce qui vraiment ce qui me désole
on a un président de la république qui a
été élu et qui a fait campagne sur la
promesse de rassembler les français
dans des circonstances dramatiques
il a invoqué l'unité nationale il est
venu devant le congrès il a présenté une
feuille de route et un calme global pour
la nation pour essayer de la rassembler
et on est 100 jours après il a été
largement applaudie par par les
républicains parce que tout le monde
aujourd'hui parce que vous dénoncez les
postures politiques
il ya bien sûr les primaires c'est dans
moins d'un an du côté des républicains
vous dites aujourd'hui voilà est-ce que
est ce qu'il ya vraiment que des votes
en âme et conscience et qu'il ya des
postures politiques puisque on prépare
déjà à près du côté des républicains la
peau la posture françois fillon par
exemple je pense que les postures sont
beaucoup moins importantes sur ce texte
que les convictions quelles que soient
les bancs sur lesquels on se trouve
parce que les calculs vous savez dans
ceux qui ont voté contre
à l'intérieur de ma famille politique y
en a que ça choque
et puis il y en a d'autres qui
éventuellement peuvent trouver qu'il
aurait fallu le réserver aux seuls
binationaux ou l'écrire domaine
différents toutes les circonstances sont
pas les bonnes je vais juste ajouter
deux choses ce gâchis sur la manière
dont on se fait le débat dans sa
fracture aujourd'hui la représentation
nationale mais pas seulement
l'ensemble de la population c'est quand
même en grande partie lié au fait que
après la parole présidentielle du 13
novembre
de semaine en semaine on a fluctué vous
dites que le président n'a pas tenu
parole tu fais ça relisez le discours du
13 novembre
regardez le projet de loi tel qu'il est
arrivé et on sait qu'en gagnant
l'assemblée nationale unifiée regarder
entre les deux ce qu ont été prises de
position des uns et des autres entre la
sortie de madame taubira se réjouissant
que ce ne soit plus entre les
interrogations à haute voix du premier
ministre pour se demander si ça servait
à quelque chose entre les confidences
distillées par le président de la
république à certains on est passé en
l'espace de plusieurs semaines à une
forme de concours lépine autour d'une
d'une proposition qui semblait simple je
pense que cette confusion ce flottement
à la tête de l'exécutif en grande partie
déboussolés et alimenter le foutoir dans
lequel on se trouve sur ce sujet et on
va regarder justement le résultat du
vote est en passant tout de suite à
mercredi mercredi l'assemblée vote sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi de révision
constitutionnelle
c'était la dernière ligne droite à
l'assemblée une épreuve de force pour
manuel valls il jusqu'au bout a essayé
il vient de rassembler la majorité les
députés ont adopté l'ensemble du projet
de loi de révision constitutionnelle
avec 317 voix pour et 199 contre le vote
en détail et les rapports de force avec
thibault le floch pour 317 contre 199
l'assemblée nationale a adopté c'est une
première étape remportée par le
gouvernement le projet de réforme
constitutionnelle a été adoptée par plus
des trois cinquièmes des députés
présents manuel valls veut y voir un
signe encourageant pour la suite de
l'examen du texte
une grande majorité des parlementaires
ou trois cinquièmes ont considéré que ça
rassemblement s'imposer au-delà des
querelles partisanes les français
n'aurait pas pardonné et ne pardonneront
pas à ceux qui ne se disent pas à la
hauteur des responsabilités
les détracteurs du texte sont ils des
irresponsables bien au contraire
répondent des députés du front de gauche
et une majorité d'écologistes derrière
le calcul de l'exécutif sa proposition
de révision consacre la victoire
idéologique de l'extrême droite qui voit
ses idées triompher alors qu'un
gouvernement de gauche est censé être au
pouvoir
l'article 2 de cette loi qui intègre la
déchéance de nationalité dans notre
constitution rencontre l'opposition
d'une nette majorité des députés
écologistes
une opposition qui s'exprimait également
dans les rangs socialistes et
républicains
mais les deux principaux groupes ont
voté majoritairement en faveur du texte
la cause si tu somalisation de l'état
d'urgence représente une avancée
incontestable pour notre démocratie
au stade où qu'elle nous en sommes nous
resterons sur un vote de cohérence par
rapport à une mesure d'évidence un
français qui bafoue les valeurs de son
propre pays qui s'attaquent sauvagement
à lui ne peut partager ni laventure
nationale ni sa destinée le texte va
maintenant être examiné par le sénat
avant de revenir à l'assemblée si des
modifications sont faites par les
sénateurs alors une première étape de
franchie à l'assemblée nationale il
reste toute la suite du parcours
législatif bruno retailleau a déjà
précisé que ça ne passerait pas au sénat
je pense que ce qu'il a précisé c'est
que la version adoptée par l'assemblée
nationale aurait du mal à être votée
telle quelle par le sénat notamment à
cause de l'apatridie je pense que c'est
effectivement un point de blocage pour
beaucoup de mes collègues
même si encore une fois je pense qu'on
sera pas sur des consignes de vote il y
aura ici une grande liberté des uns et
des autres en fonction de leurs
convictions il ya des gens qui sont
favorables à la déchéance il ya des gens
qui sont hostiles
il ya ceux qui effectivement sont gênés
par l'apatridie la
constitutionnalisation de l'état
d'urgence fera consensus de manière
extrêmement large
le point sur la déchéance à nouveau
amènera certainement des débats dans
cette maison est ce que vous croyez que
le congrès c'est fini on n'en parle plus
selon vous je vais pas me livrer au jeu
des pronostics
encore une fois j'attends aussi de voir
ce que l'examen donnera ici je suis
comment dirais-je déçu et perplexe et
déçue parce que ce qui aurait dû être
une occasion global de regarder comment
rassembler les uns et les autres est en
train de devenir un espèce de 2,2
spectacle une pantomime sur le plan
national qui est quand même assez
invraisemblable pour cela on a pourtant
rappelé qu'il irait jusqu'au bout qu'est
ce que vous dites aujourd'hui il est
temps d'arrêter le processus
non mais mais aller jusqu'au bout de
quoi de quel texte de quelle version
qu'est ce qu'elle est belle quand la
navette on aura bien une version
définitive à un moment donné mais vous
savez que pour qu'il y ait une version
définitive il faut à un moment que les
deux assemblées se mettent d'accord et
je m'étonne que en amont de l'examen par
l'assemblée il n'y a pas eu déjà dans la
volonté de présenter un texte à
l'assemblée nationale qui n'ait pas déjà
été pour partie soumis à une partie de
la majorité sénatoriale pour arriver dès
le début à une version qui soit une
version qui permettent de ne faire
qu'une lecture soit hollande a dit
rajouté lors de son entretien télévisé
qu'il ne fallait pas que la navette dure
trop longtemps est ce que ça voudrait
dire
selon vous que ce texte pourrait très
bien s'arrêter arrêtez l'hexagone ce tag
on parle d'une révision continue il a
rêvé de quelque chose de majeur et on
est dans le commentaire de la dernière
petite phrase du président de la
république pour savoir ce qu'ils
envisagent au bout du bout c'est normal
pose la question à vous poser
non je suis d'accord mais il n'y a même
pas encore eu une lecture au sénat que
le président explique déjà qu'il faut
pas qu'ils aient trop de navettes
parlementaires la fin j'ai là pour le
coup si vous voulez au titre de la
séparation des pouvoirs la moindre des
choses
nous serions partis c'est d'attendre
qu'ils aient une lecture au sénat et de
regarder ce qui se passe après et ce
serait le comble que l'exécutif essaye
de faire porter la responsabilité d'une
navette parlementaire au sénat alors
même qu'il a bricolé un texte sans
prendre le soin de s'assurer de l'accord
de tout le monde avant de le présenter
devant la représentation nationale
ou alors on supprime les 1,6
tu sion et on considère que quand c'est
l'état d'urgence le président décide
seul où le premier ministre peut prendre
par ordonnance toutes les décisions qui
veut puis on changerait et puis ça
occupe un espace mais était très
important d'adopter ce que françois
hollande nous a rappelé hier c'est même
pire que ça
si vous voulez le véritable point sur
lequel on devrait avoir un débat c'est
la constitutionnalisation de l'état
d'urgence et sait les conséquences parce
que ça potentiellement ça concerne des
millions de français on va passer un
petit peu un autre sujet mais vous
inquiétez pas dans la politique et les
élections ne soit trouvée très loin
c'est une petite révolution qui se
profile pour les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
première proposition du projet de loi
les 500 parrainages d'élus nécessaires
pour se présenter seront désormais
directement envoyée au conseil
constitutionnel et non collectés par les
candidats et la liste intégrale des
parrainages sera publié en temps réel
évitant le faux suspense parfois
provoquer objectifs de la transparence
mais les petits candidats crié au déni
de démocratie favorisant les grands
partis
l'idée qui consiste à dire que les
parrainages vous ne pouvez plus à l'est
les collectées directement cercle si
vous mettez en place ce que nous sommes
en train de faire une force vive sur le
terrain pour aller au contact des maires
pour nouer une relation privilégiée avec
certains maires et bien tout ça ce n'est
évidemment plus possible puisque les
maires devront adresser directement leur
candidature au conseil constitutionnel
autre point sensible de la réforme
l'accès aux médias une fois la
candidature validée
actuellement il y a cinq semaines
l'égalité des temps de parole avant le
premier tour le texte propose de n'en
garder que deux accompagnés de trois
semaines d'équité non plus d'égalité
c'est à dire une représentation des
candidats en fonction des résultats des
dernières élections et des enquêtes
d'opinion inadmissible pour nicolas
dupont aignan il c'est une magouille qui
vise à verrouiller l'expression
politique puisqu'elle ira plus d'égalité
du temps de parole pendant trois
semaines
là où se forgent véritablement les votes
donc c'est une volonté de des deux
principaux partis et du parti socialiste
de cadenasser d'expression politique et
de faire taire les gens indépendants les
candidats indépendants c'est une honte
la proposition de loi prévoit aussi de
fermer tous les bureaux de vote de
france au même horaire 19 heures elle
vise également à renforcer les moyens de
la commission de contrôle des comptes de
campagne qui devra à partir de 2022 ne
prendre en compte que les dépenses des
six mois précédant le scrutin contre une
année actuellement le texte débattu dès
mercredi prochain au sénat doit être
rapidement adopté car il est ensuite
impossible de modifier les règles moins
d'un an avant l'élection présidentielle
voilà pour les explications de jérôme
rabier sur section de modernisation de
la vie politique il le rappeler le texte
examiné dans l'hémicycle le mercredi
prochain vous en est le rapporteur
est-ce qu'ils ont raison les petits
candidats de s'inquiéter on entendait
l'instant nicolas dupont-aignan dans ce
reportage
avant chaque élection présidentielle il
y à un texte qui ajuste des points
d'organisation de cette élection
présidentielle en fonction des remarques
qui ont été émises par les autorités
administratives ou juridictionnelles
indépendante conseil constitutionnel csa
conseil d'état commission des sondages
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne depuis 2012 vous avez tout un
ensemble de choses qui ont été pointés
comme c'était le cas au moment des
élections précédentes et on attend le
dernier moment
donc au moment où ça fait polémique pour
proposer un certain nombre de
modifications de règles pour être clair
il ya des points qui de mon point de vue
peuvent faire consensus comme la
fermeture de tous les bureaux la même
heure c'est un moyen d'éviter que dans
certaines villes on vote alors que des
sondages sont déjà sortis et sont
suffisamment fiable pour qu'ensuite le
résultat de tonnes par an fut lancé le
temps de parole c'est le point qui va
effectivement cristallisé les
difficultés de quoi on parle entre 1962
date où on a décidé du principe d'une
élection présidentielle au suffrage
universel direct et 2007 il y avait deux
semaines d'égalité pendant le temps de
la campagne officielle et avant cette
campagne officielle il y avait un
week-end qu'on appelait
le temps intermédiaire c'est-à-dire
entre la publication des candidats ayant
500 parrainages le début de la campagne
officielle
en 2007 on a modifié le temps
intermédiaires et on a dit que le temps
intermédiaire ils allaient pu durer
trois jours
il allait durer trois semaines et en
faisant ça on a fait basculer dans
l'égalité
ces trois semaines qu'est ce qui s'est
passé on a divisé depuis 2007 par plus
de deux le temps moyen d'antenne
consacré à la présidentielle pour une
raison simple ce sont pas les petits
candidats
contrairement à ce qu'un certain nombre
10 qui sont visés c'est le fait tout
simplement que vous ne pouvez pas
organiser le débat de premier tour et
même avoir une présentation à la
télévision qu'ils soient totalement
égalitaire
quand vous avez autant d'écart entre des
candidats qui ne font pas campagne ou
qui ne font pas de meeting et je pense
pas à des gens comme monsieur
dupont-aignan
je pense à des candidats j'avais un
homme monsieur schivardi comme monsieur
chemine had même si je cible personnes à
la dernière élection présidentielle de
2012 dix candidats cinq candidats qui
ont fait 97 % des suffrages ont cumulé
cinq candidats qui ont fait moins de 3 %
il ya un an dans ces conditions est de
changer les règles du jeu est
effectivement un accès égal aux médias
aux temps de parole et en même temps en
respectant les débats des débats
démocratiques entre les gros candidats
c'est comme ça qu'ils seraient appelés
par les petits non la proposition elle
est beaucoup plus équilibré que la
caricature que certains peuvent en faire
elle ne vise pas pour être très clair a
réservé le temps d'antenne aux gros
candidats elle vise à dire on ne touche
pas à une égalité totale pendant les 15
jours de la campagne officielle mais
pendant les trois semaines qui précèdent
on renforce le principe d'équité en
faisant notamment en sorte que
aujourd'hui sur le papier c'est une
égalité mais dont l'effet les chaînes
ont le droit de programmer à 3 heures du
matin certains candidats et d'autre
entre 19 et 20 donc on corrige la
liberté éditoriale en nous assurant que
tous les candidats bénéficieront d'une
exposition médiatique aux heures de
grande écoute était dans mon enfance des
meetings la nuit c'est ce classement
tient compte d'autres éléments
on va passer à jeudi christophe béchu
car jeudi
le remaniement a bien eu lieu après
plusieurs jours de suspense le
remaniement ministériel a été annoncé
jeudi un remaniement marqué par
plusieurs retours le retour tout d'abord
2 jean marc ayrault l'ancien premier
ministre remplace laurent fabius au quai
d'orsay retour des verts également avec
emmanuelle cosse jean vincent placé ou
encore barbara pompili quatre partants
10 entre en mai une parité stricte tout
de suite on fait le point
un gouvernement arc-en-ciel avec
l'arrivée de trois écologistes
emmanuelle cosse à la tête du ministère
du logement et de l'habitat durable
jean vincent placé est devient lui
secrétaire d'état à la réforme de l'état
et à la simplification comme barbara
pompe il y est nommé secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations internationales sur
le climat gouvernement un peu plus
élargie aussi au parti radical de gauche
avec l'entrée de son chef jean michel
baylet nouveau ministre de l'aménagement
du territoire et de la ruralité
ce remaniement signe également le grand
retour de jean-marc ayrault
l'ex premier ministre rejoint le
ministère des affaires étrangères il
remplace laurent fabius en partance pour
le conseil constitutionnel une
nomination qui devrait se traduire par
un rapprochement de la france et de
l'allemagne notamment dans le dossier
des migrants d'autres surprises encore
avec ces quasi inconnu du grand public
ancienne conseillère de françois
hollande audrey azoulay devient ministre
de la culture nommée secrétaire d'état
l'une des porte-parole du ps juliette
mais adel et les députés socialistes
hélène geoffroy estelle grelier erika
barrette
il y à aussi celles qui prennent du
galon laurence rossignol nommé ministre
de la famille de l'enfance et du droit
des femmes
annick girardin ministre de la fonction
publique et celle qui quitte le
gouvernement
fleurs pellin sylvia pinel et marylise
lebranchu
voilà vous savez tout grâce à sophie
normand couturier alors que ce soit
béchu vous êtes l'un des porte paroles
d'alain juppé qui a déclaré ce matin
c'est en avant marche arrière cela ne
changera pas grand chose à la
crédibilité du gouvernement devenu
pléthorique avec quarante ministres
on voit bien que
malgré toute l'énergie que le président
de la république a pu mettre hier pour
dire que ce gouvernement n'avait rien à
voir avec la proximité de l'élection
présidentielle
comment comprendre qu'on augmente le
nombre de ministres au moment où le
temps dont on dispose ce raccourci
comment comprendre qu'on s'efforce
d'aller par des petits calculs chercher
repêché débattu à des élections des gens
qui ont déjà occupé des responsabilités
honnêtement il ya quand même beaucoup de
choses qui sont illisibles pour les
français et puis évidemment quelque
chose qui est choquant c'est le fait
qu'on et marchander sur un coin de table
un référendum
on est sur un projet d'aéroport pour
obtenir le retour des écologistes ça
traduit une chose ça traduit le fait que
ce don président voulait je pense à
nicolas hulot ou à d'autres ont refusé
de venir et qui s'est retrouvé comme la
presse le titre ce matin avec beaucoup
de cruauté mais malheureusement avec un
peu de justesse à faire du bricolage
c'est pas la route notre dame des landes
c'est du bricolage un référendum local
c'est du bricolage
on est en 2016 c'est du bricolage
que n'at-on lancé ce référendum en 2012
en arrivant aux responsabilités qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
non parce que là on voit bien qu'on est
coincé c'est ce qu'elle dit faisant de
la foule et oui on est coincé depuis un
mois on est quoi sert une fille de moins
descoings s'est visiblement donc moi je
conçois j'entends que le référendum
local peut être la solution mais tout ça
sent tellement vous l'arrière cuisine
électorale
quelle question quel périmètre si c'est
les séries de loire et la bretagne c'est
possible selon vous je ne crois pas
qu'on puisse organiser un référendum
dans deux régions un référendum local
par définition doit être organisée par
une collectivité locale
en fait je pense que tout ça ça s'est
joué hier après midi avec beaucoup
d'impréparation et donc que la question
de la collectivité qui va l'organiser de
la question elle n'est pas posé le
principe de libre administration des
collectivités fait que une collectivité
doit se saisir de saab je pense
sincèrement qu'on est sur du bricolage
en tout cas eu au moins une chose sur
lequel je partage totalement la position
du président de la république sait il
faut sortir de tout ça j'avais la
naïveté de penser que quand on élisait
quelqu'un a des responsabilités c'était
pour qu'ils prennent les décisions
écoutez ce que disait françois hollande
justement c'était jeudi soir à la
télévision
ça gouvernement qui doit agir qui doit
réformer qui doit avancer c'est vrai que
il est élargi
j'ai voulu associer des écologistes des
personnalités mais il doit rester dans
une cohérence je lui a signé trois
grandes priorités
la première c'est protéger les français
vous avez sans doute relever que les
ministres qui sont en charge de la
sécurité ont été maintenus et sont même
renforcées conforté je voulais aussi que
la seconde priorité soit l'emploi
forcément l'emploi je voulais que la
priorité et je veux que cette priorité
soit par rapport à ce grand accords que
nous avons signés la coop 21 l'écologie
l'environnement la transition et j'ai
voulu que des personnalités écologique
ou écologistes comme on voudra puisse
être partie prenante parce que quand il
ya ce grand enjeu pour la planète toutes
les bonnes volontés
moi je les accueille au top et je vous
présente tristan kino qui vient d'une
autre partenaire le scan il va vous
poser deux trois questions dans quelques
instants charmant tout d'abord sur
françois hollande
oui et retour à ce remaniement
ministériel quand alain juppé ni c'est
un retour à 2012 pour vous ce n'est
absolument pas un gouvernement de combat
qui a été mise en place
non qu'elle est absolument pas c'est un
c'est un remaniement ministériel pour
faire un peu plaisir à tout le monde
comment vous jugez aujourd'hui les
différentes nominations le retour des
verts le retour des radicaux c'est un
remaniement politiciens les verts ne
reviennent pas
quelques verres certains qui ont déjà
quitté le parti une qui était en rupture
de ban rentrer il ya un accord et un
soutien politique le parti radical de
gauche
effectivement c'est l'allié indéfectible
depuis le début de ce quinquennat il n'y
a pas de changement
j'ai du respect pour les personnalités
si vous voulez que qu'on était pressenti
mais de là à présenter ce remaniement
comme étant un événement politique
majeur je pense que même vous mêmes des
gens qui seront profondément
bienveillants vis
non auront du mal à en faire cette
lecture que vous avez encore un doute
qui permettent d'avoir un doute sur la
candidature de françois hollande en 2017
ça honnêtement je n'ai aucune idée de ce
qu'il y a dans sa tête et compte tenu de
ce qu'est le bilan qui est en train de
se dessiner un certain nombre de choses
je comprendrais qu'ils se posent des
questions
voilà tout de suite passé au scan notre
partenaire aux autres restant 7 à vous
vous êtes un soutien d'alain juppé et on
sait que les jeunes sont une cible pour
lui et on pour les convaincre on l'a vu
faire un même point dans un 18e
arrondissement c'est des jeux d'alcool
est ce que pour convaincre les jeunes ça
passe par là je pense que quand on voit
le succès de bernie sanders qui est très
à la mode en ce moment avec ses 74 ans
et qui je crois a raflé 80
presque 90 % du suffrage des jeunes
démocrates aux états unis face à hillary
clinton
c'est pas une question de profil du
candidat
c'est aussi une question de proposition
et de projet et notre bernie sanders
je le fais parce que la première chose
qu'on me dit après avoir expliqué que je
défends la candidature d'alain juppé
c'est quand même
derrière la question de la séduction des
jeunes il ya ça malgré tout qui affleure
en filigrane vous soutenez un candidat
qui a déjà un certain âge et moi je
pense très honnêtement que la politique
c'est pas les émissions de télé réalité
c'est pas le fait d'aller singer les
choses mais ça peut être malgré tout
d'avoir une forme de spontanéité dans
les rencontres qu'on a avec les uns et
des autres il faut pas être dans une
maîtrise ont fini par être comme un
robot mais dans le même temps il faut
pas se travestir et il ya une ligne
entre les deux il faut être capable de
suivre celle de l'odéon neda anti
système
j'irai pas jusque là je pense que
honnêtement il a aujourd'hui une
obsession c'est celle d'être utile à son
pays en se disant qu' il peut sans doute
être le plus à même de rassembler après
un quinquennat
entre 2007 et 2012 qui a déçu une partie
des électeurs de droite et un candidat
qui n'est pas terminé mais qui semble
devoir décevoir une partie des électeurs
de gauche
notre région il ya un rendez-vous qui
est apprécié par certains jeunes c'est
le hellfest festival ça fait polémique
avec bruno retailleau
est ce qu'on peut y croiser alain juppé
il ira séduire quelques jeunes alors
qu'est ce que c'est que hellfest
festival c'est un festival de hard rock
de rock métal alors à ma connaissance ce
festival qui accueille plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes
n'accueille pas que des jeunes si vous
voulez entre 18 et 25 ans je crois au
contraire qu'il ya pas mal de cadres à
qui sont assez fan de ce type de musique
je connais pas suffisamment bien les
musicaux d'alain juppé pour pouvoir vous
répondre si vous avez une chance de le
croiser il ya un livre dont on parle
beaucoup c'est celui de nicolas sarkozy
qui apparemment s'est vendu à plus de
cent mille exemplaires c'est ce qui est
le chiffre qui est avancé il a dit
qu'ils allaient faire des dédicaces dans
les supermarchés notamment entre le
rayon charcuterie les poissonneries
c'est une classe inattendu pour un
ancien chef de l'état que les hommes
politiques et le souci d'aller
rencontrer les français là où ils sont
c'est pas quelque chose qui me choque et
ils se moquent d'alain juppé qui lui
apparemment préféreraient les grandes
écoles
moi vous savez ce genre de petites
phrases il va falloir s'y habituer dans
les semaines qui viennent jusqu'à la
primaire et mais je pense franchement
que les français attendent autre chose
quand on regarde la situation dans
laquelle on est économiquement
socialement sécuritairement la crise des
migrants
franchement la somme des défis auxquels
on est confrontés pour que si on reste
scotché sur l'espèce de niveau qui est
celui de la cour de récré il faudra pas
s'étonner que la colère des électeurs de
plus en plus elles prennent la forme ou
de l'abstention ou de vote en faveur des
extrêmes et là je vais vous dire il
faudra pas chercher d'autres excuses peu
plus d'une minute parce que alain juppé
a déjà gagné on l'a vu qu'il a déjà
distribué certaines postes à ses proches
notamment à virginie calmels ce qui est
déjà assuré d'être maire de bordeaux
s'il gagne vous avez déjà un poste
qu'elle est prévue non merci de me poser
cette question
d'abord il n'y a rien de fait c'est
l'état d'esprit de personnes
ces primaires elles sont ouvertes
personne ne sait combien de gens vont se
déplacer pour voter et j'appelle moi
toutes celles et tous ceux qui veulent
pouvoir peser sur la prochaine élection
présidentielle à se déplacer pour ces
primaires s'autoproclamer vainqueur
c'est le meilleur moyen de ne pas gagner
une élection il ya des élections
primaires il y aura ensuite une élection
présidentielle le chemin est très long
et à aucun moment il faut effectivement
donné sentiment que les choses sont
faites en tout cas à titre personnel je
suis pas du tout dans une je suis pas
dans autre chose que dans le fait de
m'impliquer dans une élection qui compte
pour mon pays je n'ai pas d'ambition
personnelle pour nez qui arrive je les
dis et redis localement le chemin est
long on retiendra sa roue tout cas merci
beaucoup très stable ça c'est merci à
vous d'avoir participé à notre émission
germain on se retrouve bientôt sur les
chaînes parlementaires très bonne sur
des programmes
à bientôt